[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hmm
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
uh
aah
i got eyes on the animal
[Music]
[Applause]
keep it steady
damn i don't see it
you see it settle down kid she can't run
forever
[Music]
[Music]
how are you kids
amazing grown it's shocking they're both
in college can you believe that and mark
it's over
oh
oh i'm sorry to hear that
it's okay
i'm back to me
and i work
you know it's
that's great that's good it is i'm alone
at last exciting times
yeah i'm living the alan grant life it's
just gonna be lonely so free
allie
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
bison bought this land for the amber
deposits back in the 90s but we've
managed to turn into a safe haven for
about 20 displaced species the first
generation came from sorna most of the
newborn dinosaurs are here too took fish
and wildlife three years to catch the
t-rex
the t-rex is here oh yeah
yeah
all right just before you guys
[Music]
aerial deterrent system active
restricted aerospace protects the
airborne life
keeps the pterosaurs below 500 feet
airborne
said dreadnoughtus
[Music]
beautiful right
her name means fear nothing
you know that
that's another plane right
not exactly
is that a that's a co-atlas
late cretaceous should have stayed there
okay
okay
it's cool we're good it's gone
do you remember how we used to get the
raptors in the truck yeah yeah
you're up
no like a last minute dive roll i don't
have roll you'll be fine
i never got the timing right
no
no
no
no
[Applause]
[Music]
we gotta go
i'm gonna have to break a window to get
inside that thing
oh nobody's afraid of heights
[Music]
don't move
[Music]
we're talking about cascading
system-wide effects ian
gosh that's a drag what is the matter
with you
all right is there something special you
want me to do how about you give it too
much not to care hey i i gave my opinion
robustly for years as expected the sum
of our human endeavors has led to our
annihilation and the only play now
is to take the time we have left and uh
you know just like we always do squander
it multiplying like crazy and they're
not dying what part of this don't you
understand well i do understand this is
going to be a global famine hey hey we
can't anticipate everything we need to
eradicate the ones we released what all
of them no
no henry like yesterday we don't want to
cause a panic we want control
there's no such thing
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
i promise you i am gonna get her back
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible
mistake the doomsday clock might be
about out of time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i can use your expertise
you comment or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah why
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
see not so bad
[Music]
[Music]
you